call it the great american cover-up
because we've been telling you for a few
weeks that the knives were out for biden
within the democrat party
but now with the new piece of the new
york times focused on concerns about his
age and his performance we're beginning
to see just how rapidly things are
falling apart
president biden is facing an alarming
level of doubt from inside his own party
with 64 percent of democrat voters
saying they would prefer a new standard
bearer in 2024. at 79 he's already the
oldest president in american history and
concerns about his age ranked at the top
of the list for democratic voters who
want the party to find an alternative
well the times went on to speak to a
number of biden voters including nicole
ferrier
a preschool teacher from michigan saying
i don't want someone knocking on death's
door
another biden voter john waldron from
new york has is quoted as saying
you ever see him on tv and compare the
president to zombies that's what he
looks like but
why is this just coming to light now all
right we've been documenting biden's
daughtering foolishness since he
announced his run for the presidency in
2019
which begs the question
what did the media know and when did
they know it now obviously the press
knows a lot more than they're telling us
about how bad things really are inside
the white house
but they're not reporting everything
they know because they're afraid of
helping the gop now this is scandalous
because we the american people have a
right to know
whether biden is capable of actually
carrying out the duties of the office
joining me now is charlie hurt fox news
contributor and washington times opinion
editor and amela epinobi former
left-wing activist and now prager you
personality uh charlie
now the media they're only souring on
biden because
they see where the voters are right the
voters are ready to dump him so the
media seemed closer to wanting to dump
him correct yeah and also uh you know
joe biden has served his purpose and so
they don't and they realize now how
toxic he has become uh what a problem he
is the guy can't even ride a bicycle
which is a real problem um and uh so
they're starting to turn on them because
they realize that this is not
going to
carry forward very well but the one
thing the one mistake about that you
just said
you we've not been uh recording his his
daughtering foolishness just since 2019
we've been recording his daughtering
foolishness for decades
before he got into the white house he
was a buffoon on capitol hill it's just
becoming so much more obvious and the
only difference is now he's so old a lot
of us kind of feel sorry for him no i
don't i feel sorry for the country i
mean god bless you because he can do a
lot of things in retirement i mean no i
feel sorry for the country the country's
suffering because of this now amelia
today politico is reporting that a
left-wing group that worked in the 2020
election to persuade progressive voters
to actually support biden is now
preparing to turn on on him as well it's
called roots action with an email list
of 1.2 million voters and said it plans
to spend six figures on a hashtag don't
run joe campaign with digital ads
starting one day after the midterms
amela
i can hear the quacking already but this
is the lamest of lame ducks
yeah i mean i would like to say i'm
surprised by this but i think they're
looking at biden and they're seeing that
there's not a lot of longevity in this
and this is not just a young person
thing of people looking up and going
well the government looks pretty old at
the moment even people americans 65 and
older to the tune of 60
are saying you know this is not the
candidate for us anymore and it's not
just his age and the fact that he is in
clear medical decline but he's also been
in government for nearly 50 years now we
have a problem and the latest new york
times opinion piece has referred to our
government as a gerontocracy which is a
massive problem to see this many people
of this age so disconnected from real
american life sitting in government
now charlie the hill is reporting
tonight on what they're contemplating
as a doomsday political scenario for the
democrats okay it takes it's taking
shape so they're now going back and
saying well we we thought we could hold
on to the senate
but that's looking bad now because
biden's dragging down the whole party
even in some races where you know they
you might have been having some trouble
those are tightening do you see that as
well oh absolutely and and what's really
remarkable about this is that uh just
you know from 30 000 feet this you know
the map for republicans in the senate is
the worst map of the you know every two
year cycle for the united states senate
uh this is the worst map that
republicans can face the one that they
face in in two years from now and in
four years from now is much much better
but even
going against that massive headwind it
it looks like
democrats are
going to have a real hard time holding
on to the senate and the single person
who is to blame for that more than
anybody else is joe biden he the the bar
was so low for him when he came into
office all he had to do was unify the
country and instead he has wrecked the
country wrecked the economy uh and and
and made a mess of of foreign affairs
which is supposed to be his area of
expertise and he's been the reigning
expert on foreign policy in in
washington for 50 years
well here's what kamala
said about 2024 watch
up on capitol hill there is speculation
among some democrats and some
republicans that president biden
won't run for reelection in 2024 what's
your message to those who say that
listen
to president biden he intends
to run
and
if he does i intend to run with him
pamela how convincing
was that
oh she's not convincing ever she is just
as bad on camera as he is the only issue
is she can't use her age as an excuse
it's unbelievable and no i i don't think
we're going to see him uh running again
and if we do oh my gosh we're in for
some trouble
well charlie when you really think this
through the democrats are going to have
to
emerge with some
working-class
connections right like they're going to
have to have the working-class democrats
suddenly like so they're going to trot
out that john you know fetterman in
pennsylvania who's about as working
classes you know any trust fund kid out
there but i don't think that's going to
work i mean fetterman's just a big phony
so is tim ryan no because joe biden has
given in to the just left wing lunacy of
the party they're no longer they don't
even pretend to represent the working
class uh and
the exact same things that led to joe
biden getting picked in 2020
for the nomination uh are still at play
now because uh because you know the
party has moved so far away from from
their roots but do you remember the
republican ad
or rather the democrat ad that showed
the republican uh wheeling granny off
the cliff i think it was during
obamacare well that's what the media and
democrats are doing to joe biden now
they're just trying to wheel joe biden
in a wheelchair off a cliff anything to
get rid of him because they know that
they can't win uh when with him well the
media created this uh charlie and amela
great to see you both hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else